when I first saw this specimen I was
completely blown away you can see this
beautiful little tiny bird skull
preserved within this piece of amber so
I was going around showing it to
everyone like look at this it's so cool
to a paleontologist
it's weird we've never seen anything
like it I definitely like couldn't keep
a lid on this one when we think of
dinosaurs we think of these you know
huge skeletons but paleontology right
now is being completely transformed by
the discovery of skeletal fossils fossil
berta Brits preserved in amber when you
have an animal preserved in amber it
looks like it just died yesterday all
the soft tissue in place trapped in this
little you know window into an ancient
time so the specimen that we're talking
about today is a teeny tiny little bird
skull preserved in amber and when I
first saw this specimen it just blew my
mind I have literally never seen
anything like this it's even smaller
than a bee hummingbird which is the
smallest bird alive today the jaws are
filled with teeth there's over a hundred
teeth present in the jaws I had these
weird eyes sticking out looking to the
side and there's nothing like this alive
today so when we try to figure out what
these morphologies mean we really have
to use a little bit of our imagination
but to us the fact that skull is very
fused the fact that has lots of teeth
the fact it has these really big eyes
all suggests that despite its teeny tiny
size it was a predator and it was
probably feeding on small insects but
because the eyes are facing to the side
it would have lacked binocular vision
which is something we usually associate
with predatorial birds so ocular
dentists was just weird
so this lump of amber is a hundred
million years old which is smack dab in
the middle of the Mesozoic era you know
the age of dinosaurs
so this early bird coexisted with the
long-necked sauropod dinosaurs it
coexisted with flying reptiles like
pterosaurs it was part of this really
diverse cretaceous fauna and you know
these tiny
the organisms can only be preserved in
amber you know even in other places
where you have exceptional preservation
you know small things might have existed
but we don't have any evidence of it so
if it wasn't for amber we wouldn't know
about this my newt fauna at all and it's
just incredible to uncover this this new
ecological niche that we never even knew
existed right now we're only in the very
beginning of the study of these
specimens of what information we can
glean from this material like right now
we are only describing what you can see
through the amber and then the CT images
of you know so we scan the specimen and
then you can see the bones inside but
I'm hoping in the next 10 years that
we're gonna develop techniques that are
gonna allow us to access the
biochemistry of the soft tissues that
are preserved in there to be able to
look for mulana somes and the feathers
in order to determine color but also I
actually am sitting on quite a few
amazing specimens that I haven't had
time to study yet but there's a lot of
very cool things that we still have like
on the backburner that we'll be studying
very soon so stay tuned there's a lot
more cool stuff out there
[Music]